What it means to be a conservative in
the nineties and especially 2000 has
changed.
So it is true that you know that,
that the conservative,
we're not in any way anti-science,
um,
until much more recent times.
Now actually both sides are anti science
about different sciences,
but I'm in America,
the right wing,
the Republican Party.
Ha,
it's controversial,
but I do believe that the polarization
starts with the right moving further
out.
So what it means to be conservative to
the anti anti evolutionary,
which is actually what's happening on
the left now to exactly.
That's it.
This modern Bret Weinstein the other
day,
and you know,
he,
one of his claims is that evolutionary
biology has something in it to offend
everyone.
So it's a,
it's a science that's very likely to be
targeted by extremists.
You also brought up something that
actually touches on the eye on the
difficult problem of how it is that you
might define someone who is
ideologically possessed,
let's say,
or ideologically rigid,
because the idea was that you can make a
valid case for the utility of free
information flow and the free flow of
people that would go along with that and
you could make a good case for the
danger of that.
And so the idea might be that if you're
only making a case for the danger of
that,
then you're tilted too far to the right.
And if you're only making a case for the
utility of that,
then you're tilted too far to the left.
Exactly.
That's right.
And so we can look at immigration as a
nice example.
There was a recent essay in the
Atlantic,
I think it was by Peter Beinart,
where he,
um,
he reviews.
He,
it starts with a lot of quotes that are
pretty nuanced positions about
immigration from Barack Obama.
Paul Krugman,
a bunch of other people on the left who
used to be able to say,
on the one hand,
you know,
compassion,
economic,
on the other hand,
you know,
we have to have a legal process and
there's a threat to low wage workers,
so people on the left used to bill to
talk about immigration and talk about
the pros and cons,
pluses and minuses,
but beinart shows how in the last four
or five years you can't,
if you so much as suggest that will
maybe immigration is Annette.
Good,
but it might have some deleterious
effects on certain classes of low wage
American workers.
You could get in big trouble,
right?
Because that's instantly prejudicial
because immigration has become a sacred
topic.
So this is the key thing that I want
everyone to keep in mind.
We are fundamentally religious creatures
were built for religion and it's a great
achievement to create a scientific
establishment and an academic
establishment that keeps that way of
thinking out.
Scientific thinking is not natural
thinking.
Religious thinking is natural thinking
and what's happening to us in the last
few years especially is a flooding in of
religious thinking and so let's get a
bunch of social scientists talk about
immigration.
What are they going to do?
Look at the data,
way up.
The pluses and minuses.
No,
they're going to.
Many of them feel they're on a team and
that team is fighting the right.
The right is anti-immigrant.
It includes racist elements,
therefore that justifies us in being pro
and social sciences are always.
There's always ambiguity.
There's always conflicting studies,
multiple causal factors.
Is that always in the social science
study?
That's right.
So beinart point was that the left used
to be able to think straight about
immigration.
Clearly it had a,
you know,
it was generally pro immigration,
but it used to be able to think
straight,
but in the last few years a religious
orthodox mindset has overtaken it.
Okay.
So we might as well also pointed out
that it's a primordial religious
mindset,
right?
Because I mean there are Christian or
Jewish,
I mean ancient tribal,
small scale,
lots of gods.
Right,
right.
Well,
so then one of the things that you might
suggest is that when you throw out a
sophisticated religious structure,
unsophisticated religious structure
comes in to fill the gap.
I do.
So that's true.
So that's definitely worth thinking
about.
So that's right.
The thing to write with religions,
we have to clarify fundamentalism is the
problem,
not religion.
And so if you did a close tribalism,
that's right.
If you get a fundamentalist know I'm
happy to say,
and if you have people applying to a
Grad program in psychology and I find
out that they're Christian,
that's fine.
There's no problem.
But if they're fundamentalist Christian,
I would think,
well let's say let's say it's not
psychologists.
Suppose it's you know,
geology.
So someone applies to a geology program.
There are fundamentalists,
young,
earth creationist or you gonna admit
them.
No,
I don't think you should.
They're not able to do the right kind of
thinking based on what we know to be the
case.
They're there.
They're not in the scientific paradigm
in the type that's right.
So,
so if we wouldn't admit a fundamentalist
Christian to a geology program,
why would we admit someone who is just
as fundamentalist about certain moral
and political issues into a sociology
program or into a psychology program if
they come in knowing what the right
answer is committed to that right
answer,
likely to get angry at anyone who
contravenes that right answer.
Um,
and,
and showing signs of close mindedness.
I don't think they belong to grab the.
I guess the question is how in the world
do you set up mechanisms to ensure that
you're not swamped by fundamentalists of
any sort?
So those are people who are reducing
everything to a single cause.
It's something like that.
How can you implement a structure that
protects the organization against that
without the structure itself becoming
totalitarian?
Because these things,
these things spin out of control so
fast.
But so I think what we have to realize
in the academy is that we face,
I think we face an existential crisis.
We rely on an enormous amount on public
goodwill.
We get enormous tax subsidies,
a direct research support and recent
polling shows that while Democrats have
always had a higher opinion of the
universities than Republicans until two
years ago,
everybody thought universities are a
good thing.
They make life better.
So Americans had been very supportive of
higher education.
There have been rising grapes on the
right,
but it's only between 2015 and 2017 that
now republicans go from saying mostly
universities are good things in two
years.
They go way down and say universities
are bad things.
They're making things worse.
Now,
how is this news greeted?
Pundits on the left are saying,
oh,
those republicans are so anti science.
Look how ignorant they are.
They now hate universities.
Come on.
Anybody's been watching the news.
Anybody who's seen the mobs to shout
downs,
the illiberal behavior,
you know,
the metaphor I use is like,
Americans on the right and left are
really supportive of the military.
We have.
It's one of the few institutions that we
still hold in high esteem on both sides.
And so the Republicans more than
Democrats.
So suppose you had Gallup poll and I,
uh,
showing Republicans liked the military
more than Democrats,
but both really like it.
Then suddenly in 2015 we started seeing
video from all over military bases,
the military academies in which the
military leaders are overtly right wing.
They are there.
They're saying terrible things about
leftists and progressives and the
midshipmen and the cadets,
and everybody is mobbing the occasional
liberal and to behaving in a really
despicable,
scary and intimidating way.
What do you think the left would now
think about the military?
Obviously support for the military would
plummet.
That's what's happening in America with
universities.
We are losing the support of half the
country.
This is unsustainable,
especially in red states where they
control the purse strings.
So I think we have a major crisis.
I think we've got to go into crisis mode
and we've got to clean up our act.